- I found this out, I didn't know this,
but Will Smith is
actually playing your dad
in an upcoming movie, right?
- Yeah, so there's this film
coming out this year now,
it's called, or I imagine
it'll be this year,
"King Richard," and it's very exciting.
It's really about my dad
and how he literally changed
the game and how this started.
He's a revolutionary kind of person,
and I love him to death
and my mom of course
is also featured in the movie and--
Oh, there's my mom!
She's the coolest lady on
the planet, she's so fun.
But the two young ladies
that play both Serena and I,
they acted just like Serena and I did,
holding hands, hugging each
other, like how we were as kids.
We still like hug each other,
and it's the same thing.
So it was really interesting to see
that kind of dynamic on the set.
And we had a lot of fun with
them, because we would say,
just be careful, because in the year 2000,
and we'd pretend they were actually us,
you're gonna meet this guy,
don't date him, you know!
(applause and laughter)
- Just say no!
- We had a lot of fun,
those girls are sharper
than we ever were at that age though.
So we don't think we
have to worry about them.
- Oh my God, that's so funny.
You're going to meet
this guy and just run.